hello guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Taylor Bradley Taylor and I check out
from the channel top trending five
movies that had deadly real-life
consequences ooh boy this should be
exciting I'm excited should be exciting
he's something of it on the Exorcist
that can remember where my mind ow when
the character of Ghostface appeared in
the 1996 movie scream audiences all over
the world were shocked and terrified by
the actions of the movie killer however
Daniel Gil and Robert Fuller saw the
film as inspiration and real action
jamming scene where a person is stabbed
to death and hung by their on trails all
in British mind Ashley Marie Gill and
fuller dressed up as the ghost face
killer and stabbed Murray 18 times
leaving him for dead in a sickening
homage Murray however survived the
attack and was later able to testify in
court against his would-be killers for
him survive I just survived a success of
Mel Gibson's movie The Passion of the
Christ was not so surprising as it was
deadly in one showing of the film a
religious news woman named Peggy law
suddenly became overwhelmed by the
graphic violence in emotional turmoil of
the picture and promptly had a heart
attack and died in the theater
ironically enough while the Catholic
Church put out warnings against the
movie The Exorcist when it first debuted
in 1973 that film suffered no casualties
from the audience unlike this movie
which had the churches full support damn
when Thomas Mackendrick showed his
friend Allen Menzies the movie Queen of
the Damned there was no way he could
have foreseen menti spiral into madness
Menzies became so obsessed with the
critically and commercially pan movie
that he went on to watch it over 100
times in a month and spoke to
Mackendrick about it on almost a daily
basis after Menzies told his friend he
was having visions of the main character
visiting him at night
McKendrick politely let menzies know
that he was crazy
Menzies responded by bashing Mackendrick
head in stabbing him repeatedly drinking
his blood and eating part of his head
while serving his prison sentence
Menzies eventually took his own life is
correct the journal hunter a classic
1970s movie focusing on the hardships of
POWs in the Vietnamese war featured a
harrowing psychological torture scene
where the main characters are forced to
play a game of Russian roulette while
the movie in no way illustrates this
game or behavior in a positive light a
sudden and immense number of suicides in
connection to the game appeared soon
after its release while it's difficult
to find a direct correlation between
these deaths and the film itself the
timing is almost too much to simply
ignore avatars Cameron's 2009
blockbuster extravaganza avatar was also
cited as a source for a cause of death a
42 year old Taiwanese man went to see
the movie in theatres and reportedly
became overwhelmed spiking his blood
pressure to dangerous levels he promptly
slipped into a coma and died 11 days
later the official cause of death
written by the coroner over-excitement
why don't we know it
you can die from over-excitement
apparently Jesus see that was crazy
the first story interested me the most
because oh my god like this screen
movies already so meta
cuz it's about serial killers who are
inspired by horror movies right and then
in real life there were serial killer
these dude dudes who are fired by by
serial killer spy right movie that's
crazy
I can't believe that dude survived that
I know they said he was hung by his own
like entrails oh yes okay and he was
stabbed 18 times and this might seem
like the unpopular opinion thing but do
you even want to survive after that yeah
of course you want these guys to go to
jail yes you want these guys to burn
definitely but holy [ __ ]
can you imagine the rest of like living
the rest of your life knowing what it
feels like to be hung up by your
entrails and stabbed 18 times that's a
great way to get girls at a bar so that
awesome way to get [ __ ] ah yo stabbed
18 times and hugged my my insides
it was scary I'm a badass now and she's
gonna be like oh my god I'm so sorry for
you this is that's so horrible oh no oh
yeah but I survived it in I was able to
testify and put them away and I forced
them to blow me I'm I think I think he
did that if someone tried step if
someone stabbed me 18 times and hung me
and I survived that I don't think I
would want to risk a job I don't think I
would want to force [ __ ] teeth
Forsman ya ain't gonna use it with a gun
pointing at the Jesus Wow
next time he'll reject okay the Passion
of the Christ yeah that's kind of messed
up how the kid cuz I was going to
Catholic school yeah at the time Passion
of the Christ was released of course if
it's like demonic or something Catholic
Church is gonna be the new new to new
but the Passion of the Christ was so
brutal there should have been some
consent warning ya bout it the fact that
someone actually had a heart attack from
the amount of violence doesn't surprise
me it's a very violent thing PEGI law
Thank You law and there's Peggy so she's
probably from like 1910
- or something you know like her name's
who's named Peggy these days the teacher
was named Peggy how old is she she's in
her 50s
well it's reasonable she wasn't born in
the 20s I know I guess so Peggy though
is you don't want Peggy to go see
Passion of the Christ
it's not surprising to me because the
movie was incredibly violent and I'd
imagine like the older you are that
you're not used to seeing that amount of
violence in a film if you attend church
you know you don't know what happened
that's still it's a very brutal thing
there's a lot of psychology that could
play into watching The Passion of the
Christ
yeah you know like if I watched it now
it would be a totally different
experience than when I saw it a few
years ago right because I I don't
consider myself Catholic at the time I
did consider myself Catholic I'm full
hard atheist by the way guys full hard
full hearty I don't believe in [ __ ] when
you die nothing happens yeah when I
sneeze I don't ever like it when someone
says bless you Dane Cook that's when you
die nothing at what you died I think I
meant
no no I'm spiritual now um but yeah like
this woman hello she's like an elderly
lady and she's Christian or Catholic
whatever and she has these beliefs and
this like beautiful image of Jesus and
then now she's just watching the
brutality of he see because all the
movies before Passion of the Christ that
depicted the story of Jesus were Jesus
doing a lot of really amazing things and
then he gets hurt but then he comes back
from the dead in the end Passion of the
Christ
yeah he does come back in the light last
shot of the movie right but spoiler
alert spoiler Nagi's you don't know the
Jesus still it's like it just hops you
into the violent tale and that's just
like this horrendous imagery of someone
you love being tortured specially Mel
Gibson movie right yeah I feel like that
speaks volumes and Mel Gibson is one of
my heroes motive sounds great I really
liked him in um what woman one that was
a great woman - I was actually thinking
the what were you see is but what is
that Lea it is but it's like on Tools
for this [ __ ] it's a weapon lethal
weapon all the lethal weapon movies are
my favorite huntin rigs man yeah I'm
gonna crush on Mel Gibson when I saw the
lethal weapon maybe still got a crush on
them I don't know he's done some
questionable Thanks
look Mel Gibson has apologized checked
into rehab got a settlement with his
ex-girlfriend he's done everything
necessary to show he's working on
himself to grow as a human being okay
Robert Downey jr. has his back I have
his back let's move on Taylor I don't
not know okay the Queen of the Damned
thing this crazy guy eats his friend his
head parts of his hat drink his blood
you need to listen if you honestly like
hate it Queen of the Damned dude no one
liked Queen of the Damned they even said
in this video critically and
commercially pan yeah so it's sucked
with critics and it didn't make any
money but over a hundred times watching
a video over a hundred times in a month
yeah I know it's obsession that's
insanity
I wonder what caused him to be so
obsessed with the movie itself or the
characters yeah I don't know there must
have been some either a disconnect or a
super connect at the same time I'm
understanding about it you know like if
Jerry came up to me and was like hey
dude your obsession with Batman dick
jokes Ryan Gosling yeah trying to think
of all the things your estimate is crazy
he would be the only one to ever say
that and then I would I would knock him
over and I'd smash his head in with my
foot just like in the movie drive to
prove my point I think I'm just gonna
start staring off whenever you start
doing anything really inappropriate
instead of reacting who's gonna colitis
hey it's the same face Veronica gives me
anything at a certain point you just
can't be sure a wild woman just become
numb to it I'm saying yeah it's true
it's like that's when their emotions
shut down and they choose to just ignore
what I'm saying the deer hunter okay so
this movie I remember seeing this scene
yeah uh my mom was watching yeah and I
didn't even watch the whole movie but I
remember coming in and seeing the scene
and just being like oh my god that's the
scariest
ever and that was the first time I never
even heard about Russian roulette as a
game and so it's not super surprising to
me that people who are already
struggling mentally or emotionally would
see this and be like oh well Russian
Roulette is a game that real men play no
I play rush room no no you do not yes I
do with what uh with what no I got hold
of it I played it with a real gun
[ __ ] Alex we should play Russian
roulette no I think we're good Russian
Roulette reactions that's what we should
do we should watch videos playing
Russian roulette if we do reaction
reviews to them do that no it would be a
really sad video avatar avatar I had no
idea you can die from over-excitement
I choose that as my way to die but I
don't want to slip into a go by mid die
moment later I would just like to like
oh my god I'm so excited right now I've
never been this excited for my life dead
it's so weird how people like these
movies they listed I know with passion
of the christ' there was someone who
like committed a crime and turned
themselves in to jail because they were
so moved by the film really an avatar
like there are people I've heard that
like have committed suicide or attempted
suicide because they thought life will
never be as great as avatar and so for
someone it died from over-excitement I'm
like come on guys it's just a movie
it is like I'm one of the biggest movie
buffs I mean yeah yeah but I've never
been to a point where I'm like I'm gonna
die from died over excitement for me
would have to be something that actually
correlates to something in my actual
life yeah like oh you're a millionaire
and you just want a Tony and you're
proposed to and here's seven billion
puppies and I'd be like ah homicide from
over-excitement once was the first time
Veronica and I had sex that's the
sweetest thing ever she got naked and
then you almost died my heartbeat
started just going out of control yeah I
passed out had to call an ambulance had
a heart attack
survived a heart attack right it's
straight to hell then we had sex in the
hospital
good day people that's pretty romantic
pretty romance ex yeah then she bought
flowers from downstairs and brought them
to me cuz I was ill so she's kind of the
man in the relationship she's the wrong
I know yeah no she is the man in this
relationship she's not around right yes
another in the kitchen wash listen guys
that was some top training go ahead and
check out their videos they're an
awesome channel listen if you're new to
this channel though this one
the real rejects subscribe today and
then label yourself a reject
cuz it's so cool to name your fans it's
something and it's good to have a label
that you fall under yeah everyone should
be labeled everyone should be labeled my
motto and Taylor Bradley follow her on
Instagram Taylor Bradley 91 and on her
YouTube channel just launched italiano
Americana a show that features two
good-looking people living in a trailer
that the pitch
Richard poetic heart Hutchinson jr. can
i have a shout out what a name I'm from
Jamaica is that your maker the job
that was weird Jesse don't you make an
accent you just don't come on man that's
better
I have channel Richard Hudson I can do
it I'm just yelling now what I didn't
have bill and I do original poetry oh
that's awesome
no way find his poems let's see if you
have any poems um oh it's just on your
Facebook I love the bow tie it's a girl
regatta guy oh that's a girl
that's a girl is that him no no that's a
guy okay Richard that's a guy okay it
was just a picture of a girl I see he
loves bowties I love that you love
bowties and poetry I too love bowties
and poetry you look like one of those
guys who would like kidnap children in
the park no he doesn't he looks like
someone who got straight A's in school
and then you'd force them to listen to
your poetry before you sent them back to
their parents traumatized okay don't
give people ideas people who are
watching this are already probably a
little bit weird
hey this video was primarily about how
movies have influenced people I know so
you don't want giving other people idea
next step is internet personalities
influencing people listen dude if you
don't work on yourself you will become
that guy this is a really long video